En 1991, se firmó otro acuerdo de 50 años
que impide cualquier explotación en la Antártida
y este acuerdo podrá ser alterado,
cambiado, modificado o incluso, abandonado, a partir del año 2041.
Damas y caballeros,
gente muy al norte de aquí, en el Ártico,
ya están aprovechando
este deshielo,
aprovechando recursos de las zonas que estaban cubiertas de hielo
en los últimos 10, 20, 30 000 años,
hasta 100 000 años.
¿No pueden atar cabos y pensar
en por qué el hielo se está derritiendo?
Este es un lugar increíble, la Antártida,
y he trabajado arduamente
en los últimos 23 años de esta misión
para asegurarme de que lo que está pasando aquí, en el Norte,
nunca suceda, no puede suceder en el Sur.
¿Dónde empezó todo esto?
Para mí a los 11 años.
Miren este corte de pelo. Es un poco raro. (Risas)
A los 11 años, me inspiré en los verdaderos exploradores
y quise tratar de ser el primero en ir a los dos polos.
Resultó extremadamente inspirador
que la idea de convertirse en un viajero polar
era un muy buen gancho con las chicas en las fiestas, cuando estaba en la universidad.
Fue un poco más estimulante.
Después de años, 7 años de intentos para conseguir financiación,
7 años de solo escuchar negativas,
7 años de escuchar a mi familia que tengo que buscar ayuda
y consejo psiquiátrico,
finalmente, 3 de nosotros iniciamos la marcha hacia el Polo Sur geográfico,
la marcha más larga y sin ayuda que jamás se haya hecho en la historia de la Tierra.
En esta imagen, nos encontramos en una zona
del tamaño de Estados Unidos
y estamos por nuestra cuenta.
No tenemos comunicación por radio, ningún apoyo.
Bajo nuestros pies, el 90 % de todo el hielo del mundo,
El 70 % de todo el agua potable del mundo.
Estamos de pie encima de todo eso.
Este es el poder de la Antártida.
En este viaje, nos hemos enfrentado a peligrosas grietas,
a frío intenso,
tanto frío que el sudor se volvía hielo por debajo de la ropa,
se te pueden agrietar los dientes,
el agua puede congelarse en los ojos.
Digamos que hace un poco de fresco. (Risas)
Después de 70 días de desesperación, llegamos al Polo Sur.
Lo habíamos logrado.
Pero algo me pasó en ese viaje de 70 días en 1986
que me trajo aquí, y que me dolió.
Mis ojos habían cambiado de color en 70 días debido a los daños,
nuestros rostros estaban llenos de ampollas,
la piel nos colgaba a tiras y nos preguntábamos por qué.
Y cuando llegamos a casa, la NASA nos dijo
que habían descubierto un agujero en la capa de ozono
sobre el Polo Sur
y que hemos andando debajo de él el mismo año que había sido descubierto.
Los rayos ultravioleta golpearon el hielo, rebotaron, nos quemaban los ojos,
nos desgarró la piel de la cara.
Fue un poco chocante... (Risas)
y me hizo pensar.
En 1989, ahora nos dirigimos hacia el norte.
60 días, cada paso nos aleja de la seguridad de la tierra firme
a través de un océano congelado.
De nuevo, hacía un frío desesperante.
Este soy yo después de bañarme desnudo a 60 grados bajo cero.
Si alguien te dice: "Tengo frío",
y tiene este aspecto, entonces tiene frío sin duda.
(Aplausos)
Y a 1000 km distancia de la seguridad de la tierra firme
ocurre el desastre.
El Océano Ártico se derrite bajo nuestros pies
4 meses antes de lo que alguna vez lo hizo en la historia y nosotros estamos
a 1000 kilómetros de distancia de la seguridad de la tierra firme.
El hielo se estaba agrietando y resquebrajando a nuestro alrededor
y aterrado, pienso: "¿Vamos a morir?"
Pero ese día, algo hizo clic en mi cabeza,
cuando me di cuenta de que, como mundo,
estamos en una situación de supervivencia
y esa sensación nunca ha desaparecido durante estos 25 largos años.
Pero entonces, tuvimos que marchar o morir.
Y no estábamos en un programa televisivo de supervivencia.
Cuando las cosas van mal, es una cuestión de vida o muerte.
Nuestro valiente héroe afroestadounidense, Daryl,
quien sería el primer estadounidense en ir al Polo Norte
perdió su talón por congelación a cabo de 200 km de marcha,
pero tiene que continuar, y continúa.
Después de 60 días en el hielo, alcanzó el Polo Norte.
Lo habíamos logrado.
Yo era la primera persona en la historia lo suficientemente estúpida
como para ir andando a los dos polos,
pero era nuestro éxito.
Por desgracia, cuando volvimos a casa,
no todo fue diversión.
Yo estaba muy deprimido.
Tener éxito en algo es a menudo más difícil
que hacer que esto suceda.
Me encontraba vacío, solo, en bancarrota.
No tenía esperanza,
pero la esperanza apareció en la forma del gran Jacques Cousteau,
que me inspiró a abrazar la misión 2041.
Jacques me dio instrucciones precisas:
"Involucra a los líderes mundiales, habla con la industria y las empresas
y, sobre todo, Rob, inspira a los jóvenes,
porque ellos elijarán el futuro de la conservación de la Antártida".
Para involucrar a los líderes mundiales, hemos estado
en todas las cumbres mundiales de la Tierra
en las tres que hubo, con nuestro valiente yate "2041",
dos veces en Rio, una vez en 1992, la otra en 2012
y luego en la Cumbre de la Tierra en Johannesburgo,
donde hicimos el viaje por tierra más largo jamás realizado con un yate
13 000 km alrededor de toda África meridional
haciendo nuestro mejor esfuerzo para inspirar
a más de un millón de jóvenes en persona,
acerca del 2041 y de su medio ambiente.
Durante los últimos 11 años, hemos llevado a más de 1000 personas,
gente de la industria y los negocios, mujeres y los hombres empresarios,
estudiantes de todas partes del mundo, hasta la Antártida,
y durante esas misiones, hemos logrado recuperar
más de 1500 toneladas de metal retorcido que quedaban en la Antártida.
Eso duró 8 años y estoy muy orgulloso
porque reciclamos todos de nuevo aquí en América del Sur.
Mi inspiración, desde que empecé a caminar por el reciclaje
fue mi madre.
Aquí está mi madre...
(Aplausos)
mi madre sigue reciclando,
y tiene 100 años, ¿no es fantástico?
(Aplausos)
Amo a mi madre.
(Risas)
Pero cuando nació mi madre,
la población del planeta era solo de 1,8 millones de personas,
y hablando de miles de millones,
hemos involucrado a los jóvenes
de la industria y los negocios de India, de China.
Estos son las naciones agentes de cambio
y que jugarán un papel extremadamente importante
en la decisión acerca de la conservación de la Antártida.
Increíblemente, hemos logrado atraer e inspirar mujeres de Oriente Medio
que, a menudo, representaron a sus países por primera vez en la Antártida.
A fantásticas personas, muy inspirados.
Para cuidar de la Antártida
primero tenemos que involucrar a la gente en este lugar extraordinario,
establecer una relación, forman una unión
poner las bases de un poco de amor.
Es un gran privilegio ir a la Antártida
puedo decirlo.
Me siento muy afortunado,
he estado allí 35 veces en la vida
y todas las personas que van con nosotros, vuelven a casa como grandes defensores
no solo de la Antártida,
pero para cuestiones locales en sus propios países.
Volvamos al punto de partida: el deshielo de los Polos Norte y Sur.
Y no es una buena noticia; NASA nos dijo hace 6 meses ya
que la capa de hielo de la Antártida Occidental se está desmoronando.
Áreas enormes de hielo
--vean que grande es la Antártida
comparada incluso con la geografía de aquí--
enormes regiones de hielo se separan de la Antártida,
regiones del tamaño de algunos países pequeños.
La NASA estima que el nivel del mar subirá
--es un hecho seguro--
un metro en los próximos 100 años,
el mismo tiempo que mi madre ha estado en el planeta Tierra.
Va a pasar,
de que la preservación de la Antártida
y nuestra supervivencia en la Tierra están vinculadas.
Y hay una solución muy simple.
Si usamos más energía renovable en el mundo real,
si somos más eficientes con la energía,
si producimos nuestra energía de manera más limpia,
no habrá razón económica alguna para ir y explorar la Antártida.
No tiene sentido económico,
y si manejamos mejor nuestra energía, es posible también ralentizar
o incluso detener
este gran deshielo que nos amenaza.
Es un gran reto, ¿cuál es nuestra respuesta?
Tenemos que volver allí por última vez,
a finales del próximo año,
regresaremos al Polo Sur geográfico.
donde hace 30 años hemos llegado a píe,
y volver sobre nuestros pasos, 1600 kilómetros,
pero esta vez usamos solo energía renovable para sobrevivir.
Cruzaremos los casquetes polares que se están derritiendo,
con la esperanza de encontrar algunas soluciones a este problema.
Este es mi hijo, Barney.
Vendrá conmigo.
Se ha comprometido caminar al lado de su padre,
para traducir estos mensajes
e inspirar estos mensajes en otros jóvenes líderes del futuro.
Estoy muy orgulloso de él. Bueno de él, Barney.
Damas y caballeros, un sobreviviente --y yo soy uno de ellos--
un sobreviviente no mira un problema y dice: "Lo que tú digas".
Un sobreviviente ve un problema y se ocupa de este problema
antes de convertirse en una amenaza.
Tenemos 27 años para preservar la Antártida.
Nos pertenece a todos.
Todos tenemos una responsabilidad.
El hecho de nadie es dueño de ella,
tal vez pueda significar que podemos hacerlo.
Antártida es una línea moral en la nieve.
Y debemos luchar del mismo lado de esa línea
luchar duro por mantener este hermoso lugar impecable, único en la Tierra.
Sé que es posible.
Vamos a conseguirlo.
Les dejo con estas palabras de Goethe;
he tratado vivir de acuerdo con ellas:
"Todo aquello que puedas o sueñes hacer,
comiénzalo.
La audacia contiene en sí misma genio, poder y magia".
Buena suerte a todos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)